تويتر يلغي الحظر الذي فرضه على الاعلانات
السياسيه منذ عام 2019 ضمن احدث
استراتيجيه يسعى من خلالها الون ماسك
لزياده الايرادات بعد شرائه العصفور
الازرق
والخطوه الجديده ستسمح للسياسيين والعديد
من المنظمات من عرض الاعلانات التي تدعم
المرشحين او تروج لاجراءات الاقتراع او
تطلب التبرعات وفقا التي اكدت ان شركه
تويتر مقبله على احدث تغيير في سياستها في
مجال الاعلانات التي سترفع مستوى الوعي
فيما يتعلق بالمشاركه المدنيه والنمو
الاقتصاديه والاشراف البيئي وحتى
الاجتماعى وايضا توسيع ادعيه سياسيه في
المرحله المقبله بعد ان كان تحضر جميع
اشكال الدعايه السياسيه عام 2019 ردا على
تصاعد القلق بشان المعلومات المظله التي
تنتشر على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
اعلان وصف بالمهم وفق مراقبين منذ ان اكمل
ماسك استحواذ هو على شركه في اكتوبر
الماضي بقيمه 44 مليار دولار وهنا يجب
الاشاره الى ان معظم عائدات تويتر تاتي من
الاعلانات ففي عام 2021 كان ما يقرب من
5.1 مليار دولار من الارباح عن طريق
الاعلانات لكن بعدها قامت بعض الشركات
بتعليق الانفاق الاعلاني على المنصه بعد
الاستحواذ والصحاله من عدم اليقين بشان
كيفيه التخطيط السيد ماسك لاداره الشركه
وبالفعل منذ ديسمبر انخفض انفاق 100 جهه
على الاعلانات على تويتر وفقا لتحليل
البيانات من شركه الابحاث بسماكس وفقه
مراقبين فقط تويتر اليوم هو فوز واضح
لحوريات التعبير ولكن يبقى ان نرى مدى
تاثيره على ارباح الشركه خصوصا وان تويتر
المساج الى اثبات فكره ان ساحه المدينه
الرقميه هي قناه فعاله لاقناع الناخبين
وصانع السياسات
[موسيقى]